efectivamente difiere mucho la versión
oficialistas versus la de la oposición
como sabemos el gobierno Daniel Ortega
cuenta con un aparataje de medios de
comunicación que difunden información
falsa respecto a una amplia afluencia de
gente Pero por otro lado vemos
fotografía y videos de medios de
comunicación independiente y de redes de
ciudadanos que se han constituido para
poder realizar observación electoral que
realmente eso no es cierto que es muy
poca gente la que ha salido a votar
porque se sabe que es un fraude
electoral adicionalmente a eso hay más
de 400.000 nicaragüenses fuera de
Nicaragua según datos que ha presentado
ya los interamericano entonces sabemos
que es muchísimo menor la cantidad de
gente que hay en el país el año pasado
se dieron las elecciones presidenciales
y fue un total fraude y efectivamente es
lo mismo que está pasando este año
también
Le quiero preguntar cómo llegó la
oposición a la decisión de llamar al
boicota a estas elecciones Y si hay un
frente Unido O sí que hay fuerzas
opositoras que han participado de los
comicios
diversas organizaciones opositoras tanto
como organizaciones defensoras de
derechos humanos han hecho un trabajo de
denuncia porque en realidad no existen
las condiciones en Nicaragua ni siquiera
para poder vivir y tampoco para ejercer
los derechos civiles y políticos hay más
de 200 personas presas políticas entre
ellas pre candidatos presidenciales que
aspiraban al cargo como tal y otras
personalidades políticas creo que eso ha
sido el ejemplo claro de que no hay
elecciones libres que no hay ningún tipo
de libertades en este momento en
Nicaragua
precisamente de las detenciones de
líderes políticos opositores quería
hablarles Ya vimos como antes de las
anteriores elecciones hubo precisamente
estas detenciones ahora Ortega Ortega ha
dicho que estas son unas elecciones por
la paz Cómo ha sido el trato del
gobierno a la oposición desde aquel
entonces
desde aquel entonces sabemos que ha
venido una ola represiva sumamente
fuerte desde el 6 de noviembre del 2021
se dieron detenciones el 7 de noviembre
siguió el aparataje represivo y las
detenciones y este año ha seguido
cercenando las libertades en todos los
sentidos vemos por otro lado también la
libertad de asociación con más de 2.000
organizaciones no gubernamentales
canceladas y es un cierre total de los
espacios también vemos la represión en
contra de los medios de comunicación los
medios de comunicación independientes no
tienen la oportunidad de dar cobertura
de forma directa y abiertamente dentro
del territorio nacional